[Music]
let's move on to another controversy
that ABC is dealing with and this one
involves social media also on The
Bachelorette yeah and we went straight
to Becca to get her reaction so is she
standing by front-runner garret after he
was connected to some controversial
posts EG online Lauren Zima found out
Garrett is in some hot water over an
alleged Instagram account of his liking
some really controversial memes and
photos what do you say to that people
say do certain things I've done things
in the past that I'm sure I it wasn't
the best thing but I just want people to
stay open-minded to everyone I would
love to give you the first impression oh
yeah how would it change your opinion of
him if that turned out to be true that
it was his account and everything I
can't fault anyone for what they believe
and you know who's to say that anything
that I knew and likes is truly what they
believe and if they just DoubleTap I
can't speak to that because it's not me
that seemingly coming to Garrett's
defense after the news that Monday
night's frontrunner might not exactly be
the man of her minivan dreams as soon as
he pulled up in that minivan I was
smitten by him someone she's had a
harder time forgiving ex-fiance Aria
lightened egg whose set to marry Lauren
Burnham next year is re gonna be on your
season or not it seems like he's gonna
make an appearance Becca he will show up
yes we do have a conversation and he'll
just have to see that unfold if they
invite you to the wedding leave Oh even
if there was an open bar and I got that
invite back you're gonna plus-one I
don't know she's gonna need that plus
one because we know Becca's engaged so
what's it like watching the show with
her new fiance we talked through
everything he knows everything that
really went on and it'll be tough to
watch back I'm sure but before we get to
see the proposal there's still plenty of
drama ahead
I only are asking for uncie for me
buyers that's all I want
what about that Hospital moment there's
an ambulance a pool of blood what can
you tease for us about what happens
there yeah it was bloody and it was it
was a lot of injuries rolled in one okay
is everybody okay now everyone is okay
now okay yes drama more than hearts
getting burning the Dean right
[Music]